♪ ♪
>> Lawrence: TIME FOR OUR 2020
ROUNDUP.
IF YOU THOUGHT BERNIE WAS A
LITTLE OFF HIS ROCKER BEFORE,
WAIT UNTIL YOU HEAR THIS.
SANDERS IS PROMISING TO REVEAL
INFORMATION ABOUT ALIENS IF HE
WINS THE WHITE HOUSE.
WATCH.
>> IF YOU GOT INTO THE OFFICE
AND NEW FOUND OUT SOMETHING
ABOUT ALIENS, UFOs, WOULD YOU
LET US KNOW?
>> I'LL TELL YOU.
MY WIFE WOULD DEMAND THAT I LET
YOU KNOW.
>> IS YOUR WIFE IS A UFO?
>> SHE'S NOT.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE ANY ACCESS?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY ACCESS.
WE WILL ANNOUNCE IT.
>> Lawrence: HE'S APPARENTLY
SMOKING.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
I HAVE NEVER SMOKED IT AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE.
>> Greg: YOU ONLY DO THE
EDIBLES.
>> Dana: I WOULD SAY.
TRYING TO BRIBE FOR VOTES.
PEOPLE WANT UFO INFORMATION.
I WILL DO IT AND THEN I PROBABLY
WON'T.
>> Greg: THERE ARE UFOs AND
THEY ARE LIVING IN BERNIE'S
HAIR.
THEY ARE MICROSCOPIC.
EVERY CANDIDATE DOES DO THIS.
THEY SAY THIS AND THEN ONCE THEY
SEE THE FILE, THEIR BRAINS ARE
ERASED.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY MEMORY OF
IT.
>> Donna: 22 MILLION-DOLLAR
PROGRAM CUT OUT DURING THE
SEQUESTER.
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN KNOWING
IF THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE HERE.
>> Lawrence: I DON'T BELIEVE
IT.
>> Dan: DO YOU REMEMBER THE
WACO RANCH?
THERE WAS NO MOONLIGHT.
THAT SKY CAN GET PRETTY BLACK.
YOU SEE SOME CRAZY STUFF.
GREG IS RIGHT.
EVERYONE SAYS THEY ARE GOING TO
GIVE US A BIG UFO FILE.
THERE IS NO YOU A UFO FILE.
>> Dan: THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T
KEEP A SECRET.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING -- I'M
TELLING YOU DO YOU THINK THE
GOVERNMENT IS KEEPING THE
SECRET?
>> Lawrence: HOW DO YOU NOT
KNOW?
HOW MANY PRESIDENTS DID YOU WORK
FOR?
>> Dan: PEOPLE SWORE TO ME
THEY SAW THE REAL ZAPRUDER FILM.
>> Donna: THE NAVY REPORTED
SEEING SOMETHING RIGHT
ALONGSIDE.
>> Dana: IT WAS A FLY.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT
YOU TO THINK.
>> Donna: AND ALSO ANOTHER
UNIT SAW SOMETHING OVER ARIZONA.
THERE'S SOMETHING OUT THERE.
>> Dan: I THINK BERNIE IS OUT
THERE ENOUGH THAT IF THERE WAS A